bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 78 société
c'était une promesse de François
Hollande une fin de vie dans la dignité
ce vendredi deux parlementaires dont
Jean-Léo neti vont remettre leur rapport
à Manuel valals si les deux députés
semblent vouloir écarter la question du
suicide assisté et ne parlent pas de
Naas il propose toutefois une
possibilité de sédation profonde et
terminale quelle fin de vie pour demain
c'est à cette question que nous
tenterons de répondre avec nos invités
Claude vanevelde bonsoir vous êtes
délégué départemental de l'ADMD
l'Association pour le droit de mourir
dans la dignité Christine jeunevois
bonsoir vous êtes coordinatrice
départementale de soulager mais pas tuer
c'est un nouveau collectif qui vient de
se créer afin de dire non à l'ethanasie
et docteur Claude grange bonsoir vous
êtes responsable de l'unité des soins
palliatifs au sein de l'hôpital de de
ouans alors les soins palliatifs ne sont
pas développés partout en France mais en
tout cas ils tiennent une place
particulière dans les ivelines oui tout
à fait il y a trois unités de soins
piatifs un cler demeure à Versailles à
la verrière et puis à l'hôpital de
woudan mais c'est pas partout en France
comme ça et vous nous expliquerez ce que
sont les soins paliatif voilà on
pourrait les développer davantage c'est
sûr euh donc ce vendredi deux
parlementaires jean-léonetti et Alain
clay vont remettre un rapport
parlementaire sur la la fin de vie il y
avait déjà une loi la loi Leonetti en
2005 qui proscrivait l'obstination
déraisonnable du corps médical et la
prolongation artificielle de la vie de
la vie la première question que j'ai
envie de vous poser à tous les trois
c'est qu'est-ce qu'une belle fin de vie
Ron de B j'oserais dire une une fin de
vie non pas choisie mais une fin de vie
que l'on estime pour soi dans dans sa
liberté de choix digne point voilà et ce
n'est pas la même définition pour tout
le monde on est bien d'accord je je
salue vraiment le travail j'ai lu ce que
vous avez fait j'ai j'ai lu des articles
sur vous un travail poussé en soins
palliatif comme le vôre doit résoudre
bon nombre de problèmes malheureusement
on ne le rencontre pas partout c'est une
fin de vie digne pour les gens qui le
souhaitent ainsi d'autres personnes
veulent en finir avant d'arriver à ces
extrémités d'attendre de de façon assez
passive une mort bon une fin de vie
digne c'est une fin de vie qui
correspond l'idée que chacun s'en fait à
un moment donné au moment où où ça
arrive Chine je le vois c'est quoi une
belle fin de vie belle fin de vie c'est
une fin on rêve tous he d'une belle fin
de vie on rêve tousun fin de vie une fin
de vie dans laquelle on pourrait être
soulagé des douleurs physiques
accompagné dans ces
douleurs
psychologiques peut-être soulager de ces
angoisses d'abandon et de ces angoisses
existentielles qui surgissent toujours
en fin de vie et être accompagné aussi
par ces proches voilà être avoir une
main qui nous tient la main et partir
paisiblement voilà là vous vous
retrouvez hein sur C choses docteurange
c'est quoi une belle mais jusqu'à sa fin
naturelle jusqu'à sa fin naturelle c'est
pas précisé une belle fin de vie on ben
on meurt comme on peut il y a des
personnes qui meurent dans la colère
quitter ses proches quitter des
personnes que l'on aime c'est pas facile
euh moi je dirais plutôt il y a trois
besoins essentiels d'une personne en fin
de vie c'est ne pas
souffrir c'est ne pas être abandonné et
de faire des choses qui correspondent au
souhait de la personne donc à partir du
moment où on répond à ces trois besoins
déjà c'est c'est beaucoup h mais il y a
des personnes personne n'a envie de
mourir c'est les conditions du mourir
qui pose problème qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de de ce rapport qui sera donc
présenté vendredi on a déjà des des
fuites dans la presse en tout cas de
certains d'un des deux parlementaire qui
qui dit oui non à un suicide à assister
mais oui à une sédation profonde et
terminale cl VVEL c'est pas ça un pas
mais c'est pas tout à fait V tout le
monde je pense j'ai j'ai lu l'article
liber
bien s'exprime o effectivement il a F
des choses alors que le le rapport devit
êtreis directement au membres du
gouvernement bon peu importe et
effectivement il s B il n'avait pas on
comprend entre les lies qu' n'avaiit pas
le même point de vue qu'ils essayent de
faire consensus pour présenter un
rapport qui qui puisse servir de de base
de travail parce que derrière il y aura
proposition de loi il y aura c'est pas
ce rapport là qui est la loi soyons
clair c'est un rapport de mission ça n'a
pas force de loi derrière travail
parlementaire il y a une proposition de
loi qui est déposée le 29 janvier par le
groupe écologie des vers on a travaillé
avec eux en coloc il y une quinaine
jours tout à
fait tout à fait voilà c'est c'est tout
à fait ce rapport ce rapport qui va être
présenté vendredi alors et alors dans ce
rapport qui est présenté vendredi pour
ce qu'on en comprend pour ce qu'on en
sait je trouve que c'est très difficile
de prendre partie sur quelque chose qui
n'est pas officiel donc je ne vais pas
aller très loin là-dessus mais on
comprend à peu près entre les lignes
qu'on va passer du laisser mourir qui
était la loi Leonetti à un faire dormir
euh voilà pour euh pour améliorer ces
quelques derniers jours ces quelques
dernières semaines qui n'étaient
peut-être pas complètement prévu dans la
loi lonti mais je pense si autre chose
qui pour moi très important par contre
et je pense que là aussi on sera
peut-être d'accord c'est que les
directives anticipées vont être
opposable et contraignante ce qui n'est
actuellement pas le cas est-ce qu'on
peut expliquer ce son les directives
anticipé parce que euh je crois qu'il y
a que 3 % des Français qui font des
directives anticipées docteurange bien
les directives anticipées c'est donner
la possibilité à une personne de dire je
sousigné souhaiterais ne pas être
prolongé de façon artificielle ne pas
être maintenu par une alimentation
parentérale ou par une hydratation
parentérale ne pas être mis sous machine
si je fais une déétresse respiratoire et
de pouvoir bénéficier de des soins
d'accompagnement et des soins palliatifs
c'est dans dans les conditions du mourir
de pouvoir dire ça je veux ça je veux
pas c'est juste un courrier que les gens
c'est un courrier daté signé quand on
est plus capable de le de le faire et ça
peut être avec deux témoins qui signne
mais en effet le fait que on puisse
rédiger des anticipés et surtout que les
médecins puissent appliquer les
directives anticipées parce que si on
les fait si elles sont pas appliquées
c'est quand même ça pose problème mais
est-ce que la famille peut s'opposer à
ces directives qu'un médecin peut peut
s'y opposer B une famille non c'est
forces de loi directivement anticipé
donc on doit les respecter mais elles ne
sont pas opposables donc un médecin
pourrait ne pas les là elle risque
d'être euh oui d'être cont pour ne pas
les suivre le risque oui d'accord
auourduiou d'accord aujourd'hui oui mais
là il semblerait que là la loi
évoluerait vers des directives
anticipées contraignantes maintenant euh
et votre regard mais oui contraignant
jusqu'où c'est-à- direire ça dépend de
ce qu'on nous demandera de faire hein
puisque nous clairement en soin
palliatif
donc on est pour aussi accompagner une
personne la
soulager mais pas aller jusqu'à faire
mourir et donc si on nous demande de
faire mourir donc là nous ça nous posera
un problème parce que donc en tant que
médecin moi j'ai pas fait médecine et
les soignants n'ont pas fait médecine
pour donner donc donner la mort donc et
je trouve ça très très curieux euh il y
aura un micro trottoir et je serais très
intéressé par ce micro trottoir parce
que je veux dire euh mais je connais le
résultat puisque toutes les enquêtes
sont pareilles je crois que la dernière
enquête disait 80 96
% tout dépend tout dépend tout dépend de
comment on pose la question c'està dire
que si vous êtes atint de malédit grave
dans des souffrances épouvantable ne
souhaiteou pas qu'on apprêche votre vie
on se demande pourquoi il y a pas 100%
qu même 4% de gens qui choisissent les
souffrances épouvantables donc il y a
peu de personnes qui vont vouloir TER
parce que les soins palliatifs sont mal
connus
le problème c'est que moi ça fait 15 ans
que a priori j'ai les personnes qui sont
concernées par le sujet et quand elles
sont soulagées accompagnées et quand on
fait des choses qui ont du sens pour
elles ell me demande pas de mourir elle
me demande plutôt un rap de
vie donc là ça pose un problème entre de
se projeter dans une situation où on
n'est pas et d'être confronté à des
malades qui sont dans la situation de
fin de vie et qui me demandent pas ça à
ils arrivent en avant d'arriver à
l'unité de soin piatif il demande
certainement qui me demande pas ça à
partir du moment où il y a cette prise
en charge parce que dans il faut savoir
que il y a une inégalité et le rapport
de la CCNE l'a montré hein une inégalité
des conditions du mourir dans nos
établissement mais c'est hallucinant
donc et c'est moi je comprends qu' est
cette demande là quand nous médecins on
n'est pas capable d'assurer des fins de
vie paisibles je comprends que les
personnes souhaitent abréger leur vie je
pou réagir aussi ma question sur ce
rapport qu'est-ce que est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous vous en attendez oui
alors ben je voulais juste réagir un
petit peu effectivement sur l'écueil des
directives anticiper c'est que on va
enfin il faut qu'elle soit vraiment
réduite dans le temps parce que si on
peut pas projeter la façon dont on va
réagir et évoluer quand on sera
confronté à la difficulté de de la fin
de vie donc ça c'était une chose nous ce
que enfin ce que on retient dans ce
rapport et qui nous alerte c'est donc
sur cette sédation terminale euh
jusqu'au décès et dans un délai
raisonnable euh voilà on dit attention
est-ce que c'est pas une façon de de de
légaliser une euthanasie déguisée euh et
on dit attention à à la banalisation de
la sédation la sédation est un un moyen
qu'on a effectivement pour soulager des
souffrances mais qui a utilisé avec
beaucoup de précaution qui est
d'ailleurs utilisé avec beaucoup de
précautions qui a utilisé au cas par cas
parce que chaque cas est différent et de
vouloir instituer un droit à la sédation
terminale nous on tire la sonnette
d'alarme parce que voilà c'est déjà un
petit peu introduire une mentalité
euthanasique dans dans et dénaturer du
coup la loi Leonetti qui ne voilà qui
qui disait pas d'euthanasie pas
d'obstination des raisonnbles non plus
mais un accompagnement de la de la
personne je voudrais revenir sur less
palliatifs parce que c'est question des
stations rendant les soins palliatifs
qu'on comprenne bien unité soins piatif
sdation moi je voudrais Remond dire sur
la sédation c'est parce que je voudrais
que vous réexpliquiez
ce je je parce que vous la pratiquez la
sédation oui la sédation pour moi il y a
deux sédations il y a une sédation
palliative c'estàdire de laisser la
possibilité à une personne si elle est
dans souffrance inacceptable pour elle
de faire en sorte qu'on la mette dans un
sommeil euh pour une durée
déterminée pour une duréemin c'est pas
un sommeil pour
tuer l'intention c'est de faire dormir
pour pas vivre l'insupportable deux et
pour donner un répi à la personne aussi
voilà il se peut aussi qu'au terme de
cette sédation la personne nous dise
mais attendez je croyais déjà que
j'étais non mais laissez-moi dormir on
peut la laisser dans un sommeil mais on
donne des doses justes nécessaires pour
induire un sommeil h un sommeil ça fait
pas mourir et puis il y a une deuxième
sédation c'est la sédation en cas
d'urgence c'est-à-dire une personne
consciente qui est en train d'étouffer
et qui est en train de mourir de vie de
de de de se voir mourir étouffer ou
mourir d'une hémorragie
et bien ça me paraît donc le juste soin
de faire en sorte qu'elle ne vive pas
l'insupportable de se voouloir mourir
touffé et de la mettre dans un sommeil
pour par qu' lu support c'est ce qu'on
peut appeler une sédation terminale ça
c'est une sédation dans une situation
d'urgence mais la sédation n'a pas
vocation à le faire mourir c'est de son
hémorragie qu'elle va mourir c'est de sa
détresse respiratoire qu'elle va mourir
la sédation ça permet à ne pas que la
personne vivent l'insupportable de se
voir mourir étouffer l'intention étant
bien de soulager et non pas de la faire
mourir ENF je suis pas complètement
d'accord sur le terme la sédation
terminale tel qu'on la voit venir et
telle qu'elle a déjà été évoqué par
ailleurs c'est aussi le fait de dire
telle pathologie on on voit très bien
qu'on est en phase totalement terminale
on sait qu'il y en a encore peut-être si
on ne fait rien qu'il y en a encore
peut-être pour 8 8 jours 15 jours
peut-être un peu plus mais pas on
connaît l'échéance on n' pas la date
effectivement on connaitt l'échéan et
éventuellement enfin l'idée serait de
dire à quoi sert de plonger quelqu'un
dans une sorte de alors je ne suis pas
médecin donc je vais sans doute employer
les mauvais mots mais dans dans cet
endormissement très profondement de
toute façon il ne sortira pas pourquoi
se donner ce ce mal alors que le geste
est le même quelque part vous savez en
faisant ça que la personne va de toute
façon nécessairement mourir vous vous
voyez moi mon problème par rapport
àacord sur le fait que la sédation
terminale telle que ce présage n'est pas
ce que je dis voilà d'accord ça je suis
d'accord avec vous hein mais moi ce que
je dis c'est que moi jeonnais je me
reconnais dans une sédation palliative
et dans une sédation en situation
d'urgence mais j'entends votre
différence hein euh par contre je veux
dire que
euh moi c'est un interdit quand même
fondateur de toute société donc et le
problème c'est de
euh à partir du moment où on autorise ça
les limites on sait plus tellement où
elles vont s'arrêter donc moi ça
m'inquiète en plus de ça euh on voit
très bien en Belgique ce que ça
donne où on recule à chaque fois c inter
frontateur donc c'est c'est curieux
quand même que la France est abolit le
droit de de faire mourir même pour les
crimes les plus abjects et que
finalement quelque part on risque de
réinttroduire le droit de
euh de faire mourir pour les personnes
les plus vulnérables
donc sur notre évolution donc de notre
société je pense que ça questionne moi
je trouve que c'est un interdit vous
comprenez les inquiétudes du docteur non
enfin moi je suis nettement moins
inquiète parce qu'effectivement on a le
recul de la Belgique de la Suisse des
Pays Bas bon si plutôt figure de
repoussoir la Belgique mais non du tout
non non si vous lisez quand vous lisez
la lo au
dép oui quand vous regardez la loi au
départ elle est extrêmement encadrée et
restrictive he pour voilà c'est pour les
personnes en fin de vie atteint de
maladie incurbl et cetera et quand on
regarde 10 ans plus tard d'abord le
nombre d'euthanasie a doublé en 5 ans
ensuite on euthanasie ça a été multiplié
par 3 en un an le nombre de personnes
atteintes de maladies neurologiques y
compris une maladie d'alimer donc ont
pas forcément donné leur consentement
ensuite maintenant on peut euthanasier
des enfants en Belgique son l'itage
voilà en euthanasie ti des gens qui sont
en prison et qui ont comme seul
motif que ils sont déprimés d'être
incarcérés voilà et au Pays-Bas à ce
pointl parce qu'il y a quand même une
règle de B je finis juste au Pays-Bas il
y a une pression sur le Parlement
actuellement pour autoriser l'euthanasie
des personnes de plus de 70 ans qui
invoquerit comme seul mobile la fatigue
de vivre tout ça pour dire que quand
même une fois qu'on ouvre un peu la
porte et que effectivement on donc la
sédation complète totale pardon ça
ouvrirait la porte terminale ça ouvrir
la porte ah oui oui parce que là il pas
question d'eutthanasie question pas
question d'ethanasie mais mais je vous
dis que cette sédation terminale après
bon il faudrait savoir comment elle va
être utilisée mais par exemple déjà ce
qu'on voit le rapport SICAR dit que 80 %
des médecins ne savent pas utiliser les
nouvelles techniques qui permettent de
soulager la douleur et à fait voil voilà
et parallèlement aussi que la sédation
est de plus en plus utilisée et de voilà
de plus en plus utilisée quand même moi
je fais le rapprochement c'està dire que
si on si on on sdatee plus facilement
ben peut-être que pendant ce tempsl là
on est moins formé à soulager la douleur
donc c'est voilàah la sation c'est une
forme de soulagement de la douleur aussi
oui mais il y a d'autres façons de
soulager la douleur en gardant les gens
conscients jusqu'à la fin il y a des
gens qui peuvent vouloir être conscients
jusqu'à la fin je pense qu'il y a une
mauvaise utilisation de la sédation par
contre je pense que dans les situations
qui le nécessitent la frilosité voir
donc la réticence des médecins à
utiliser les sédation quand c'est
nécessaire ça creusera le l d'ethanasie
si on n'est pas capable d'assurer des
fins une vie paisible à des personnes
dans des situations où c'est nécessaire
oui ça creusera l'ethanésie parce que
des personnes qui ont vu leurs proches
mourir dans des conditions épouvantable
ils disent plus jamais ça ils on raisé
qu'il a une volonté politique pour
former les médecins les étudiants en
médecine les soignants justement en 99
quand vous avez ouvert l'unité de soins
palliatif à l'hôpital de de Oudan ça
devait être un peu révolutionnaire entre
guillemets comment c'était perçu à ce
moment-là oui alors vous voulez donc
parler des structures de de siniatif
donc en gros il y a tr trois structures
donc il y a la démarche palliative qui
devrait qui devrait être instilée dans
toutes les structures de soins et encore
là il y a beaucoup de de choses à faire
dans les épades dans les masses la
démarche piative devrait être inilée
dans toutes ces établissements
sanitaires et médico-social et c'est pas
encore le cas et un manque de formation
cruelle au niveau des médecins parce que
les médecins sont davantage dans le
guérir les soignants dans le prendre
soins il y a un décalage très important
entre les in et les soignants ensuite il
y a des équipes mobiles de soatif qui
interviennent dans des centres
hospitaliers pour aider dans des
situations justement de fin de vie les
différents service et puis il y a les
unités spatives qui ne reçoivent que des
situations les plus complexes de fin de
vie pour essayer de faire en sorte que
et bien la fin de vie se passe le
plusfort pour résumer c'est un
accompagnement vers la fin de vie sans
douleur c'est la douleur euh c'est
accompagner les personnes par contre la
souffrance et moi je préfère employer le
mot douleur pour la douleur physique qui
est le mot souffrance pour tout ce qui
est psychologique social spirituel ça on
pourra pas le gommer parce que une
personne les personnes elles ont pas
envie de mourir et et de quitter sa
femme de quitter ses enfants qui sont
pas encore qui sont encore petits je
veux dire que c'est forcément de la
souffrance et cette souffrance on pourra
pas on pourra l'accompagner mais on
pourra pas la gommer ou alors on fait
perdre conscience à la personne et il y
a plus de vie de relation hein nous on
est très surpris de voir comment la fin
de vie peut être un grand moment de vie
à partir du moment où les gens sont
paisibles et confortables alors des gens
paisibles un grand moment de vie je vous
propose d'écouter maintenant un extrait
d'un d'un témoignage qu'on peut
retrouver sur votre chaîne Youtube le
docteur Claude gr c'est une femme qui
atteint d'un d'un cancer cellulaire je
crois que c'est unage qui date 2008 et
voilà vous l'aviez reçu quand elle est
arrivée à l'unité des soins palliatifs à
l'hôpital de woudan on écoute ce
témoignage quelle représentation vous
aviez de rentrer dans une unité de soin
palliatif est-ce que ça vous faisait
peur oui oui oui parce que on en parle
pas suffisamment
on n pas suffisamment au courant
de c'està dire c'était quoi c'était
unité STIF c'est là où on va
mourir un peu un peu c'était ça c'était
un petit peu cette peur cette crainte de
dire bon ben voilà on m'emmène là parce
que c'est pour finir mes jours et que
c'est terminé il y a plus rien à faire
et c'est terminé que bon ben on tire un
trait terminé c'est vous savez quand je
me couche le
soir je me couche sereine ou pourquoi
parce que je sais que j'ai un tout petit
bouton h et que si j'ai un problème quel
qu'il soit je peux appuyer dessus h et
que dans la minute qui suivra il y aura
quelqu'un h nonon voilà donc pour
l'instant l'objectif qu'on s'était donné
d'essayer
hein pour le temps qui vous reste à
vivre qu'on s'est compé oui puisque
c'est vous qui nous l'avez dit oui bien
sûr et bien de faire en sorte que vous
viviez le mieux possible le plus
confortablement possible voilà
exactement c'est ce que pour l'instant
on y arrive à peu près on y arrive à peu
près oui
alors dans ce témoignage on sent cette
femme extrêmement soulagée d'être au
sein de votre unité on sentait qu'elle
souffrait avant et en arrivant chez vous
elle a elle a moins souffer physiquement
et et moralement pourquoi les soins les
unités comme la vôtre ne sont pas autant
développé que ça en France on on voit
que dans les ivelines c'est relativement
bien développé il y a quand même une
vraie inégalité de territoire sur la
question oui mais maintenant on voudrait
pas guettoiser donc la mort dans les
unitésative c'est la démarche palliative
et cette façon de prendre en charge les
malades qui devrait se généraliser dans
tous les services où on décède parce que
il y a en gros donc 120 unités de soin
palliatif en France de tidli ça fait
1200 lit il y a en gros 150000 personnes
qui relèveraient de soin patif en France
on voit bien que 150000 personnes ne
pourront pas rentrer dans dans 1200 l
donc il s'agit pas de créer des
unitésatives partout mais c'est cette
culture palliative et cette démarche
piative cette personne est arrivée elle
était douloureuse et elle était en
oclusion c'estàd qu'elle vomissait ses
selles et quand on la voit comme ça et
donc là arrivé dans cet état là qu'elle
demande l'euthanasie bien sûr vomir ses
sell et donc là soulagé là on a pas
envie de lui faire une piqûure pour la
faire mourir parce que elle en a aucune
envie d'
pas elle le demande pas
mais elle l'aurait elle l'aurait demandé
elle l'aurait demandé euh dans la
situation où on oui mais c'est ce que je
voulais dire tout à l'heure c'est que le
fait d'avoir fait ces directives
anticipées moi je les ai faites depuis
15 ans j'ai écrit plein plein de choses
dessus et je ne sais pas pour autant ce
que je demanderais déjà je ne sais pas
ce que je vais avoir comme pathologie je
ne sais pas de quoi je vais mourir je ne
sais pas quand et je ne sais pas à ce
moment-là ce que je demanderais
exactement je rien ne disent parce que
c'est à ce moment-là que la question va
se poser c'est pas 15 ans ou 20 ans
avant c'est au moment où la question se
pose face à un MDE g puissent avoir le
choix entre de toute façon c'est une loi
de liberté c'est un droit offert c'est
un droit supplémentaire c'est n pas une
contrainte c'est pas une obligation le
jour où on a ouvert le droit à
l'avortement on n' pas obligé toutes les
femmes à avorter le jour où on ouvre le
droit à choisir cette forme de chose a
pas d'obligation vous voyez ce que jeux
dire en fait ça çaappelle de réflexion
ce que vous dites d'abord est-ce que le
choix est toujours librement fait euh je
ne suis pas sûr parce que finalement la
personne malade qui est faible et
fragilisée est quand même soumise à un
certain nombre de pression consciemment
ou inconsciemment celle de pas vouloir
peser être un poids pour sa famille
celle d'être de devenu inutile pour la
dans un service tel que celui du docteur
qui est à côté de moi non d'accord mais
tout le monde ne passe pas dans mais
tout le monde ne passe pas dans des dans
des unités de soins palliatifs comme ça
et c'est bien notre regret et c'est bien
notre revendication que ce soit que la
culture palliative soit soit étendue et
et puis aussi finalement la légalisation
de
l'euthanasie viendrait un peu modifier
nos rapports dans la société quand même
parce que il me semble que à vouloir
mettre en avant la liberté individuelle
et en en voulant faire une une société
autonomiste en fait de gens qui disent
voilà c'est mon choix c'est mon corps
c'est ma vie j'exige finalement que la
société fasse ce que ce ce que je
demande et bien finalement ça va être
la personne alors on va on va dire que
c'est les médecins bien que ce soit pas
leur vocation mais c'est sûr eux que ça
va tomber quand même donc ils vont être
obligés peut-être de poser des des
gestes qui ne sont pas en conformité
avec leur conscience puis d'une certaine
façon aussi à force de tolérance ou de
fausse compassion qui s'apporne
peut-être plutôt à de l'indifférence on
va dire aux gens bah vous tu veux mourir
bah c'est vrai ta vie a pas beaucoup de
valeur finalement et bien meurs voilà et
même je vais du tout comme ça que je
vois les choses l'encadrement
égal
non parce que
l'adute
V voulais juste finir qu' on plutôt une
société plus solidaire où on prend soin
les uns des autres voilà où où la
relation les uns avec les autres est
privilégi les cas en tant médecin on
voudrait pas êre simplement un exécutant
de directive anticipé donc parce que
dans ce cas-là autant en face de
l'hôpital mettre euthanasie patenté et
que voilà mais le monde de la santé et
le monde du soin je pense que voilà je
crois qu'il faut pas être pris par ça
moi je voudrais revenir oui pu on va
conclure avec problème de l'éthique he
parce que souvent on met en avant donc
ou la mort de la dignité donc la dignité
moi je pense qu'elle est imprescriptible
elle est inhérente à la nature humaine
je veux dire que mourir dans la
digignnité moi je suis d'accord mais
c'est c'est la situation qui est indigne
une personne elle reste digne même avec
sa perte d'autonomie même gravement
malade je dire tout tout être humain est
digne même gravement malade même donc
avec toutes ces dépendances elle reste
digne parce que une une personne humaine
est digne par essence c'est la situation
quelquefois qui est indigne et dans ce
cas-là changeons les situations et les
conditions du mourir donc voilà il faut
maîtriser sa fin de vie mais chacun sa
façon de derrière le mot maîtrise chacun
met la définition qu'il souhaite ben
merci en tout cas à vous trois d'être
venu sur le le plateau on na pas le
temps malheureusement pour écouter le
micro trottoir mais à priori voilà merci
en tout cas à vous trois d'être venu sur
le plateau de C suite société pour
évoquer la fin de vie merci beaucoup
bonne
soirée